Hello and welcome to this video on the exercise setup.
So in this video we're just going to go through and we're going to get ourselves ready so that we can do the exercise.
So to start with I am going to fire up the Epic Launcher.
And then I'm going to go over to the library tab here.
And I'm going to hit launch on the engine version 5.32
which is the latest as of the time of recording.
You however can use any version you want to.
I'm then going to wait for this to fire up.
I'm then going to come under the games templates
and I'm going to select the third person template.
I'm selecting this because this will have a skeletal mesh
and a whole load of animations that we can use.
I'll just leave the project on blueprint
and then place it somewhere and hit the create button.
Once this has fired up you should see a project which looks a little bit like this.
Now if I was to hit play
you can see that we have Quinn here
and she is already fully animated
and can move around the level.
I am going to want to disconnect that.
So I'm going to come down into the content browser
and I will dock the content browser in the layout.
Now I'm going to go to the content directory within the project.
Right hand click.
And I'm going to create a new folder.
And I'm going to call this my-animation-blueprints.
I'm just going to use this directory so that I can just find all the files that I'm working.
I will jump into the my-animation-blueprint directory.
Right hand click.
And under animation
we have a selection for animation blueprint.
When I select that
it's not going to automatically create the blueprint.
It's going to ask me to specify a skeleton.
And in this case I'm going to use the SK underscore mannequin.
And I'm going to push create.
Now I will name this my-animation-BP.
I've just prefixed it with my.
And you'll see me do this a fair amount during the exercise.
I'm just doing this because it helps me identify the files that I'm working with.
I'm going to come back to the content directory.
I'm going to go into the third person directory and into the blueprint directory.
And here you will find the BP third person character.
Now I am going to duplicate this third person character.
And I'm going to put a my at the beginning here.
And I'm going to move that blueprint into the my-animation-BP directory.
This means that we have our own character pawn to work with.
Now in the world settings
I am going to come down to the game mode.
Do the drop down.
And with the default pawn class
I'm going to change that to my third person character.
So that means that we've now using the new blueprint as our pawn class.
One last thing I want to do.
And that is jump in and double click on the third person character.
This will open up the blueprint for the third person character.
I will dock it at the top here.
And in the components I'm going to find the skeletal mesh.
And you'll be able to see under animation
we have the animation class APQuinn.
Now if I search for my
I'm going to swap that over to my-animation-BP class.
I'm going to compile and save.
Now we'll find that we can still move around the world.
And we can still jump up and down.
However, we just have Quinn here in the aid pose.
So there is no animation going on at all at this point.
But that's great.
Because this is what we can then use to build it all back again from scratch
throughout the rest of the exercise.
And with that we have finished the setup for the exercise.
In the next video we'll be able to jump in
and start creating our own animation blueprint from scratch.